welcome back to new rockstars what if
episode 5 showed us the mcu through the
lens of the walking dead and also put
together the most unlikely team-up
imperials that we've ever seen and also
do we have to keep watching vision die
like can we get a break like one time
like i've seen vision die more times
than i've i don't know
said the word the today and i said the a
lot today anyways this is rogue theory
the show where we pitch the wildest
theories for the nerdy titles that we
love my name is mt and going rogue with
me today is the always hilarious and
always incredibly talented jessica
clemens what's going on just hey i was
paying attention
[Laughter]
that's no one saw that she was totally
paying attention the entire time
um and also the soon-to-be newest papa
in the new rockstars universe tom
michelson congratulations tom thanks
guys if you hear uh screaming in the
background uh i'm gonna tell my wife to
wait because we gotta do new rock stars
first but then i'll be jetting out right
after this so just just a quick heads up
okay step by step thank you name your
baby after me and then also we have
program and also a prolific gamer and
zombie hunter extraordinaire angelica
trey what's going on
ah that was such a good like title i
love that zombie hunter let's go hey you
got the proof you got the proof you got
the bow and arrow you were zombie hunter
like on twitter i see yeah it's gonna be
here all right so
what if episode five the latest episode
pretty crazy we got a bunch of zombies a
lot of crazy [ __ ] and we see that
everyone is infected on earth but are
there other characters who haven't
arrived to our planet at this point in
the timeline safe from the virus like
are captain marvel the guardians of the
galaxy and whoever else is out there
free from the infection or could we see
these zombies still leave the planet and
infect those people what do you guys
think i think this is um in the timeline
this er well in the movies timeline so
we have hulk bruce banner slashing into
the santorum and so he's gonna he was
supposed to relay the information that
uh thanos is coming right so i think we
still have who we haven't we have
guardians we have captain marvel and we
have thor still up in space whether or
not because at the end of the episode we
see thanos getting all the stones so
even with the gun and getting all the
stones we still have rocket groot and
him going to get the storm breaker um to
go get the the sword hammer so i think
the since those people are out there
they haven't yet got the infection
because it is on earth but with that
being said that doesn't mean that those
zombies can't go into space because as
we see in the episode they're still able
to use their equipment they're not
allowed to speak but they can still use
their equipment so they're smart enough
to know how to use their powers and how
to get to where they were so i think the
specific people that would do that are
the minions of thanos that were already
there they're able to go back into space
and they can infect those that are still
in space um but that is what that's what
i think that's why i think i don't think
people in space have it right now but
they could still get it
i think it's not impossible unless
you're built like
the hulk and you have the skin that
is impenetrable
so far okay okay
right all right so you think it's
possible i think you're okay i think
it's possible
i definitely think it's possible too if
it hasn't already happened right we've
seen everyone still have their their
powers so it's just a matter of time
before
they run out of fresh live food and they
start to venture out i don't know how
long necessarily the the zombies can go
without feeding so to speak but i
definitely think it's going to spread
out across the universe
yeah 100 i think that um one way that
they could spread across the universe is
we know we've seen dr strange and wong
being able to open portals and we know
that from endgame that they were able to
open a portal across planets
maybe you know the magical side of the
marvel universe will be how they get
across the galaxy um but they're they're
gonna be leaving the planet for sure i
mean come on they're probably gonna be
leaving the what if series and we're
going to get a marvel animated zombie
show after this because it was so
popular
um but yeah i think you know i think
that this is actually one of the first
signs of of how this show might all
connect and and wrap up and make sense
because i'm wondering now um if the
zombies are going to
jeopardize
all the realities and all you know not
just space but like other timelines
other realities because the watcher has
made it really clear that you know he
doesn't want to interfere because he
doesn't want to jeopardize other
realities but what if
what if
like in the comics you know what if what
if uh they do branch out to other
timelines and realities and that's what
you know causes the watcher to actually
do something and that's what could he
could say you know what now we got to
bring the heroes of the multiverse
together and and fight these threats and
in that on that same thread like you
know they there's other people that are
alive too maybe that chitauri are alive
maybe the squirrels are alive and you
know now it could be a zombie army of
people versus the space side of marvel
that are you know have now come to earth
to try to make this happen who knows the
last thing i was going to say is i also
am wondering if one way they can branch
out because the other thread that
they've been they've been you know the i
think that they've been kind of hinting
at is this tentacled schuma gorath or
whatever multi-dimensional monster this
is
what if somehow the zombies get their
hands on that guy
zombify
his ass and then now he maybe can help
them travel or do whatever i that's
already like that that would be insane
i'm trying to think of a weight barrier
yeah that would be worse
you need like 80 storm breakers to take
care of that guy but i'm wondering if
that's if this guy being some kind of
interdimensional timeless being will be
a way
to get zombified because they're not
going to have galactus in this you know
like they had in the comics so they're
maybe they'll use this guy as a big bad
to help them yeah move and spread i
don't know like the flood and halo does
he have a mouth
we haven't seen have we no i don't know
how are you gonna spread it
that's true
has teeth maybe i don't know oh why why
did you give me this mental illness
why did you give me
[Laughter]
i like the idea i i with this episode
and what you're saying i i i was
wondering when does the virus stop
because we saw that he couldn't get
vision because he was basically a
walking computer i love him i'm allowed
to say that and call him that so i was
like is there another
kind of species out there that it's
biased too and what if that is the giant
tentacle monster it being like one of
the most powerful like because like dr
strange had to absorb its power in the
last episode so i'm like i know they got
doctor strange but i'm like what if it
doesn't like it like what does the virus
there's a lot of not this episode is
amazing but there's loose ends where i'm
like you didn't answer this and i need
to know
like that is one of the biggest things
and i like the idea of the big bad in
this episode just being hank pym because
we're not we're giving him the same
credit as we give iron man where we're
like we need to remember that iron man
is the reason for a lot of problems that
are happening in the mcu just like hank
pym is the problem for this like i i
don't
he's the big bad but i want to know
where the virus would ever stop if it
wouldn't go for the tentacle monster or
any other being off the planet right or
if it would mutate right for different
species gamma variant i don't like the
hulk because you know he's fighting all
them zombies and scarlet witch granted
she's not like the scarlet witch maybe
she's still wanda you know hot topic
wanda in this but you know maybe she
could somehow infect him i don't know
like
god forbid the worst person to get the
virus in the mcu got the virus
i was like what's the point i was like
what's the damage it's done it's over
just done i was like she's a zombie
that's just like i'm gonna tear up the
entire universe
i was like okay that's a good point jess
actually she's uh she might be a nexus
zombie
and maybe
that could be a way
all of a sudden whoa it just got real
she was trapped in that mirror but she
should have just bounced out into any
could have exactly bounced out yep this
is a now we got a nexus being zombie
that could just oh man blow the doors
open like that opens the door for like
all sorts of craziness like now like
technically the zombies could show up in
like a loki or a multiverse of madness
type situation yeah in live action like
we could see these guys in live action
which would be super dope
season two you guys better do that yes i
think the virus probably couldn't attack
that many with the
uh the uh mutant gene now that i'm like
thinking about i was like how how would
it affect the people with the mutant
gene where like a lot of them can like
regenerate themselves kind of not like
how the hulk can or colossus you know
maybe yeah you can't bite through that
how the hell do those people how do
those people get attacked
yeah i have a lot of loose ends i got a
lot of questions
these zombies are
they are like persistent because i even
like they're intelligent right they were
climbing hope and like punching through
that visor
and a lot of the zombies flying yeah
yeah a lot of a lot of the ones we've
seen at least in other media they're
sort of dumb and slow and and you know
they don't they just have like a base
instinct so yeah there's a lot of
options with these zombies and i'd also
like to know
that
um i've never rooted for a zombie couple
before until i saw
freaking wanda and vision i was like no
i started crying over there the saddest
part that it's in new jersey so it's
probably the plot of land that you
wanted with here
they're gonna have the whole wanda
vision series but zombies
we were like we're going to new jersey
and it was so dark too like i wouldn't
this was so dark a vision to be like
yeah i'm just chopping up pieces of
t'challa to feed my wife
like she's hungry
i gotta feed her something mega dark i
was like i can't believe that i was like
it turned into like saw three
immediately and i was like
you know and the fact that that came out
yeah
the fact that that came in too like when
we got when they got to the compound
they found visions like we could make a
cure i was like okay i know where this
is going we're going to be done in about
five minutes and then when
when i vision gave that look it's like
you won't find what you're looking for i
was like wait what what is go and then
all of a sudden i was like okay i had no
idea what the hell was going on this
episode i thought i did but i didn't
yeah it just went crazy in a good way in
a good way these are all fantastic
theories i'm going to give the ladies 1
000 points each but i got to give my man
over there the
father to be 2 thousand points whoa
thanks i appreciate that because now i
gotta give some points yeah my future
sudden so thank you yeah i appreciate it
so he actually is at one thousand like a
restaurant yeah
one thousand points for you one thousand
that i got a thousand child credit for
extra thank you i appreciate it
but yes we've got some more theories
about where the god of thunder was
during the zombie outbreak but first
there's some brand new limited edition
changshi expired shirts over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and it's called
the great protector and it's got a cool
dragon design and it comes in three
colors there's a limited supply of these
so snap one up quick and you'll be
getting yourself a cool shirt and you'll
be helping support new rockstars and all
the content that we make so get yourself
some great new dirty gear at new
rockstarsmerch.com but this episode was
also brought to you by upstart if you're
carrying a credit balance month after
month it can feel like you're in the
never ending cycle of debt like the
cycle of violence you find yourself in
when your father is a thousand-year-old
killing machine but upstart can help you
make that final payment so that you can
break the cycle and get ahead because
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment i literally
used it the other day
the process for applying is very quick
upstart knows that you're more than just
your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit but unlike
other lenders upstart considers your
income and current employment to find
you a smarter rate for your loan and
with a five-minute online rate check you
can see your rate up front for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars you can receive funds as fast as
one business day after accepting your
loan so find out how upstart can lower
your monthly payments today when you go
to upstart.com
rogue that is upstart.com
rogue and don't forget to use the url to
let them know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application so please go to upstart.com
rogue and we also want to thank
bluetooth for sponsoring this episode
because guys there's nothing sexier than
confidence and bluetooth can help give
you confidence where it counts because
bluechu is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
and you can take them anytime day or
night and so you can plan ahead or just
be ready whenever an opportunity arises
now the process is simple sign up to
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made
in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discreet
package so if you could benefit from
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform luchu can help and we've got a
great deal for our listeners try
bluetooth for free when use our promo
code rogue at checkout and then just pay
five dollars in shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code rogue to receive
your first month for free so visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank blue chew for sponsoring the show
so let's get on to our second topic of
the day where the hell did thor go
during all this because with asgard
being destroyed in ragnarok and now
earth fully infected where do thor and
the remaining asgardians go like where
else in the universe could they
establish a new asgard and like why
didn't thor help earth during all this
like what the hell is going on what do
you guys think he's a god
so jess already mentioned this but with
the timeline of this episode it is
parallel to infinity war so
that means that thor is somewhere
like building stormbreaker i suppose or
like eventually thor is going to come
back
and
what end up in wakanda right and uh get
experience with the zombies firsthand
that way even though wakanda's safe
right now
um so i think that's just sort of if we
do want to align
the timelines here
and assume that it's
pretty parallel then yeah that's the
case
i think i agree with angelica agreeing
with me
i think cars up in space but i do like
the idea if we want to shake up the
timeline a little bit asgard finding a
new home within wakanda
so what if it ran this rogue theory so
i'm trying to go
so what if in the time like
take away the timeline a little bit but
like what if instead of uh like all the
fighting happening or just like because
we have zombie thanos right now somehow
uh the valkyrie finds her way
um to wakanda and in wakanda they're
like why would you leave because i think
it's good to acknowledge like they're
they're there for everyone now they're
aware that they're like open now so i
think they would be like just make a new
land here like we have all this land you
can just take the south side you can
take the part on the other side of the
tracks like go ahead you only got about
50 people anyways it's not going to be
that big like i'm sure they wouldn't
mind the help against them yeah exactly
and i think it would be really fun for
like even them to learn because when we
see the new asgard they're just like
building and moving logs and doing stuff
i think it's really fun to see how they
work with like winston c dukes like in
the mountains tribe in wakanda and just
learning from each other and learning
how to like just the agriculture and
also how to fight better and also about
the technology of wakanda so i would
love asgard and wakanda to become one
but just still they they have their own
land in their own space but they're just
still like within wakanda so i would
love for asgard to be there i love uh
jessica agreeing with angelica who
agreed with jessica earlier i really
like that um that was really great
um but yeah and i think you know like
like they were saying yeah thor is
definitely out i think the space part of
the story is still happening so
guardians are still there um thor was
still getting storm breaker and i guess
uh thanos must have
caught
peter and gamora at um and nowhere cause
that's how he was able to that's how he
has a reality stone already at that end
scene um he probably brought uh gamora
to vormir sacrificer got the soul stone
and that's how he has all the stones but
what's interesting is like i did i
missed it the first time i thought that
picture of zombie thanos was like out in
space somewhere he's in wakanda like
he's already penetrate if you if you
ipod deposit and see that he's
surrounded by dora melange and other and
so the zombies bang on the wall we're
trying to get out
and uh and so they so thanos is already
there and peter and t'challa and scott
lang's head are about to land in wakanda
that's already been taken over and
overrun
so
i think that they're gonna land and then
we'll have the moment of thor and rocket
and groot coming down
and then it's going to have to get real
there and because hopefully thor
survives and this time goes for the head
because you we all know in zombie shows
you got to gotta take off the head but
um that's the part that i'm a little bit
because it seems like they have taken a
little bit they're taking some liberties
with the timeline because thanos only
went to wakanda in infinity war because
the mind stone was already there yeah
with so now in this one's oh he's
already taken over so unfortunately
maybe umbaku is already a zombie maybe
he's not oh no maybe shuri's a zombie
maybe she's not because if he's taken
over wakanda there's probably only a few
people still like not zombified who
knows yeah well he still has he's still
looking for that last stone right
the mine stone and they're bringing in
that's insane yeah they're bringing it
to him pretty much he's there waiting
for it
so they could still be alive the people
that were around uh
vision's body also so i looked back at
the hand that i got from disneyland and
i was like which stone is on the front
and i was like it's the mine stuff yeah
but yeah so they they could still
potentially be alive and he might have
just got the guards guarding wakanda
right sure yeah or just not to say that
he's still not gonna get it what's his
end plan
he's still trying to get the the whole
thing but it's like when you're eating
flesh you don't really need no so i
think what he's gonna do is he's gonna
he's gonna if he can even think this
clearly because he's a zombie he wants
to double the population and make more
food if anything instead of cutting
people in half he wants to make double
or triple or whatever i think that's
what that is here's the thing though
right if you're like a really hungry
zombie or if there's a horde of zombies
and you're hungry wouldn't you be eating
the whole body it seems like they're
just biting people so it seems like this
zombie virus just kind of drives you to
get bitey and aggressive kind of like a
like a rage virus
um but they're they're undead so i
am trying to figure out this this end
plant here is it just like
at the beginning they ate the people
they straight up ate the but then i was
also like they ate aliens so maybe
they're eating aliens but not eating
people then hope would be like a buffet
i think that that's like just normal
zombie movie rules like yeah sometimes
zombies want to eat the whole body and
sometimes you just want to turn people
it depends on whatever the story needs
yeah i think it's a very disney thing of
being like we can't show them eating
captain america right i'm gonna give
everybody 3 000 points for that amazing
commentary everybody gets 3 000 points
because i love all of you so we still
have tom in the league but that leads us
to our rogue question you guys ready for
this yes
because by the time that this episode of
rogue theory is out the matrix
resurrections trailer will have
premiered but none of us have seen it
yet so right now give me your wildest
predictions for the plot of matrix 4 or
what we could see in the trailer so it's
called matrix resurrection so i think
they're going to resurrect neo
who is the one but not the first one and
they're also going to resurrect
the the first one everyone's resurrected
and uh today we're gonna have all
training resurrected yeah all the ones
everyone i'm wondering if they're gonna
like tie in you know they're gonna
definitely because the matrix was ahead
of its time as far as like tech and
computers i wonder if now they're going
to try to tie it into our world now so
like it'll have to do with like cell
phones and apps and like maybe even
social media like jumping in
and vr who know they're probably i
wonder if they're gonna be they're gonna
try to tie it into all this stuff and i
feel like if they do it it's a really
slippery slope uh to do it cool it's
gonna be really tough but i think they
might try to resurrect either that or
they're gonna resurrect the old phones
that nokia phones are the ones that you
pop and slide out all those old cell
phones that's what they're really
resurrecting yeah can you imagine
could you imagine vr in the matrix where
it's already like it already
well no it's not vr you're it's it's a
simulation
yeah so it's like a simulation within a
simulation wow that's next level
okay so we got
we got over the matrix resurrection boom
right um and i think there's uh it's
gonna be two of them right and they're
gonna two matrixes
two matrices major scenes
right yes and they have to break into
this building to get this formula
it's like it's like a it's like an
anti-gene i don't know what you want to
call it like a like uh
to get to destroy this virus that
got everybody in the world right so they
break into the building there's a bunch
of booby traps and there's a little girl
there that says that you are all gonna
die down here
and
then one of them turns into nemesis
i'm like okay you got me i don't know
that much about the matrix you were
close i know keanu reeves is in it you
were close remember justin
matrix reloaded there was the beginning
where trinity had to jump in and you
know go into that building to steal
something so you were you're probably
picking up something like that okay
i got you i got you i've seen you yeah
yeah i got you what if in the matrix
like we got super cyberpunk with it and
we were like jumping consciousness
if left neo could jump like bodies and
consciousness i know he could probably
change his body like i know kung fu yeah
yeah like all i don't know what if we
get all like ghosts in the shell on it i
don't know that would be cool i would
love to you know just like hackers um
and it's a bunch of teens
matthew lillard and angelina jolie are
breaking into the system what if this is
like a major form of synergy because
when you said cyberpunk i was thinking
cyberpunk the game and then keanu reeves
is in the game and then neil jumps into
the video game and this is a whole xbox
series x commercial
or you know
it's glitching and then at the end which
everybody wants to go buy cyberpunk yeah
that's probably what happens yeah it
starts glitching and they refuse to give
people's money exactly yeah yeah yeah
and then they explain why it's okay
this is a stab at you cyberpunk give me
my money
well these were all amazing pitches but
you know what i've got to give
a whopping 3 000 points to miss angelica
trey i really did
i really dig that idea i dig it it's
just
it's so good of an idea that everyone's
like that's all you could like anything
i love the theory of the ones and the
cyberpunk consciousness stuff yeah
yeah um making angelica our winner of
the day
congratulations to jericho let's get
collapsed oh thank you
my future son won't eat but that's okay
congratulations
[Laughter]
well that is it for this episode of
rogue theory i want to thank our guests
jessica clemons tom michelson and
angelica trey please follow them all on
social media and follow them whatever
they're doing they're all doing amazing
things please do that because they're
all my nerd buddies we love supporting
nerds but also support our channel by
checking out that new lace obsession
shirt inspired by shanghi that great
protector shirt as well as our great
merch at new rochester's merch.com
follow me on mastertainment if you want
to see some weird [ __ ] most importantly
follow us at you know new rockstars on
twitter and everywhere we are so you
think you can see all the weird cool
stuff that we post all right see you
guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you